i think they're still the same bouncing
up every year at the end of the day like
we i don't know like it does the bronze
it's the browns
any talk like that's going to be
disrespectful we definitely didn't
appreciate it and
killer we made that known tonight
same old brown
the man himself baby
the browns is the browns indeed
you know chris we make our picks on
thursday we lock them in on thursday
when i saw on thursday night that quote
from juju smith schuster the browns is
the browns right i paused i stopped
i tried to talk myself out of thinking
that that would in any way influence my
read on the game surely at this level
words like that won't matter peter king
was with me on friday he did as he is
want to do
downplay the impact of words on a
football team these are grown men after
all this kind of thing doesn't affect
them this doesn't motivate them the
browns is the browns
i'm sorry but in hindsight juju smith
schuster who has provided multiple teams
yeah gratuitous motivation throughout
the course of the season
and may have worn out his welcome
permanently in pittsburgh that's a good
question brown's is the browns is the
exclamation point on how the steelers
mishandled juju smith schuster's
messages and ultimately paid for it with
their playoff lives yeah well again you
know i'll say like hey i don't of course
it's not like the difference in winning
and losing a football game but does it
add you know extra motivation extra
little focus from the other football
team another reason to you know get the
rallying cry in the locker room and and
just be totally you know focused and
like you know honed in on the football
game friday saturday sunday to help you
out maybe just a little bit more sure
definitely does it help maybe the energy
in the locker room for the football team
you know even the day of the game you
know guys will walk in that day and the
browns is the browns guys and you know
start saying stuff like that and that'll
get energy going the locker room oh yeah
that's right jew juice miss shuster okay
you know so that it is a real thing as
much as people want to deny it i don't
say it's like hey they win or lose
because of it but it is a real thing to
your point
but let's think about where they were
yeah last week browns were and how easy
it would have been as the walls are
closing in with all of the various covet
19 issues and then you're not going to
have
your head coach and the nfl which has
been so malleable to use one of the
words you've been working on quite well
by the way thank you to be so malleable
about all things covet 19 and then
refuse to come up with a creative way to
allow kevin stefanski to be involved
from his basement which would be easy to
do you got mike tarico at home calling a
game on saturday tony romo at home
calling a game on sunday and the browns
don't have their coach so easy for the
browns to just allow this feeling of
we got as far as we were going to get we
got to 11 and 5. it's not meant to be
let's just use this as the building
block for next year so easy to slip into
that
until the browns is the browns that's
the thing
that may allow you
to break out of that spell that can
happen right we've all been there in one
way or another in one form or another
where you just feel like oh this just
isn't meant to be this just isn't our
day and you got to find a way to rise
above it and when your opponent helps
you rise above it with the browns as the
browns you do rise above it and you are
the ones who are focused and you are the
ones who execute and not the ones who
come out and airmail a snap over the
head of ben roethlisberger to start the
game like super bowl 48 are you kidding
me marquise pouncey let's just go ahead
and do the goats of the weak draft now
goats in a bad way marquise pouncey what
in the hell and then there was a key
play late in the game where he had a low
snap yeah right i mean come on marquis
you're the veteran you're the seasoned
pro you're the guy who's who's the
stabilizing force on the offensive line
and that set the tone now look the
steelers could have overcome it seven
nothing became 28 nothing but man to
have it seven nothing out of the gates
like that
that that didn't help and the browns
were focused and the steelers weren't
you know mike tomlin
didn't have his guys ready and mike
prefer did who would have thunk it
no i know i mean who would have thunked
it yeah yeah it's like pittsburgh kind
of went in like hey we're gonna be fresh
we're the pittsburgh steelers we've been
in the playoffs we always beat the
cleveland browns you know they're they
went in just
you know chest puffs puffed out feeling
like you know we're invincible we're not
going to lose this matchup cleveland did
have the the fear factor whoa you know
it is the steelers whoa we barely beat
them last week and they didn't play some
of their starters you know so there
there was some extra things there on
their side at least as far as human
emotions to make sure you're ready for
the football game to like to what you're
saying because it looked like one team
came out flying high ready to throw
their body around and do whatever it
took and another team that just thought
oh we're the machine of the pittsburgh
steelers and we'll find a way to win it
and i mean marquis pouncey and then big
ben
and then you know oh snap over your head
one man route throw the ball over the
top of benny snell's head by three feet
interception i mean the next drive is
can't convert a third in one and you
gotta punt the football i mean just
everything about the pittsburgh steelers
that we saw over the month of december
other than that one half against the
colts
it all kind of came back up in the
playoff moment here and it just was an
absolute debacle in disaster in the
first half
my guess is the steelers just thought
they were going to show up and check the
box yeah and for the same reason the
browns should have said wait till next
year the steelers may have been saying
wait till next week who do we play next
we go to buffalo oh we're going to
buffalo the ravens beat the titans we're
going to buffalo let's go right uh and
and uh
yeah no you're not going to buffalo and
you know what i i don't want to go well
i don't want to go too deep down this
rabbit hole but can't help but wonder
whether or not the steelers at some
level thought that the road was going to
end next week anyway they don't want to
go to buffalo right i remember demurius
thomas telling me several years ago when
the broncos lost in the division around
the colts where they would have had the
patriots the next weekend this was five
years ago this year the flake gate game
where the colts had to go to new england
for the fc championship he was telling
me guys didn't want to go to denver they
just didn't want to go
and uh well they got their wish oh no
they didn't want to go to new england
yeah they didn't want to go to new
england for the afc championship game
they got their wish they didn't go the
colts beat them yeah i wonder if at some
level the steelers are thinking we got
our asses kicked by the bills not that
long ago we don't think it's going to be
any different uh maybe we don't want to
go no no maybe it's a combination of
believing they were going to easily
maybe some guys in the locker room think
we're gonna easily easily beat the
browns and other guys are thinking why
are we prolonging this let's just get
this over with let's just get on with
our lives with all these lockdowns and
covet 19 and all this testing but we're
if we're going to lose the bills anyway
let's just get it over with now well
that's not in their thought that's not
the steelers you you know that if
anything i bet about one of i bet at
least at least
five out of fifty three guys
maybe more i i had that creeping around
in their brain i don't believe
they're not getting to the super bowl
this year so what's the point that this
is the level of that i'm just saying
it's a stew of is this still of
distracting emotions that the coach
needs to iron out of all of them whether
it's we think we're going to easily beat
the browns or we have an ass kicking
waiting for us in buffalo
they're very different but they are
similar in so far as they get you off
the mark and the steelers were clearly
off the mark last year clear clearly off
the mark i i just you know
hey they scored almost 40 points in the
second half i don't i you know i think
it was like your first thing you said
it's over confidence it's where the
pittsburgh steelers you know we've
played playoff football we're just gonna
show we've seen this before i mean we
saw this a few years ago when the
jacksonville jaguars came to the town of
blake bortles you know it was the same
type of thing you know well that's
because that's because they were waiting
for the rematch right thomas that one
who talked about the rematch sure they
were waiting for the patriots right like
they were puffing their chest out then
like hey there's no way we're gonna lose
this we're gonna go that i mean it just
had that way about it and again i don't
know if that's really what it is it's
just but what we watched on tv last
night was one team that was clearly
ready to play more physical had a
different energy about them and and and
you know mike maybe you're right maybe
the marquis pouncey snap that just does
enough to kind of you know
mess with the flow of the football game
there a little bit but
either way pittsburgh is going to come
away from the game and just look at it
and go man juju smith schuster wow okay
before the game he gives them bulletin
board material marquis pouncey bad snap
big ben
damn interceptions deontay johnson yeah
it wasn't a perfect pass but oh you
dropped balls again too oh it's the
short passing game that everybody knows
you're gonna do right defensive lineman
just stick your hand up because he's
gonna throw it right by your ear hole oh
tipped in the air throwing at the vance
mcdonald interception it's just like all
the issues with the steelers all came in
the first half of the game and it was
just like sorry it's over right here see
you later it's cleveland's time and uh
hey
they move on cleveland and baltimore
played better than pittsburgh the month
of december i don't even know why we're
so shocked you know i we were all fooled
by the steelers the emblem big ben mike
t all of it we all were
remember two weeks ago when they won the
division and they partied like it was
1999 i i i was like boy this this this
is a team that that seems a little too
happy to check the boxes division
champions
maybe they knew maybe they knew what was
coming remember there was a sense that
we had during their losing streak
they're not going to win in the post
season but then they drew the browns and
we thought okay they'll at least prolong
it by a week because they're not going
to lose to the browns at home they
haven't lost to the browns at home since
2003. ben roethlisberger during his
career drafted in the first round of
2004 never lost at home
to the cleveland browns it's amazing
what do you think about it it makes you
wonder which way it's going for big ben
going forward that's something we're
going to be talking about a lot we're
going to be breaking down a lot in the
coming days and weeks because
and look i don't want to go too far down
that rabbit hole today because we've
we've got we've got plenty of other
things to discuss let's hear from ben
and then i'll decide how much time i
want to spend today on an issue that
will dominate the next couple of weeks
which is what's been going to do in 2021
here he is from immediately after the
game
gonna start from being god a lot of
praying um and then you know a lot of
talk with my family discussions
decisions and
um you know i still have a year left on
my contract uh i hope the steelers want
me back if that's the way we go and um
there'll be a lot of discussions but but
now's not the time for that
i think it was important that he pointed
out he's got a year left on his contract
and i hope the steelers want me back if
he would retire
he would owe the steelers 12 and a half
million dollars for unearned signing
bonus money that's 12 and a half million
dollars that's a lot of money yeah write
that check back right
but he's got a 41 million dollar cap
number that kicks in on march 17 and
he's got a 15 million dollar roster
bonus that's due on march 19. there may
be a story behind the story here where
if he decides he's retiring
he's hoping that maybe they just cut him
because if they cut him he owes zero and
we're talking about twelve and a half
million dollars this isn't some trivial
amount this isn't something this isn't
this is a lot right so
and and and when we saw the emotion last
night it's hard to think
that he's not at least contemplating
awesome no doubt this is last time in a
stealer uniform and here's here's the
next and i don't want to go too far with
this today
but when you see these other
quarterbacks that have had a second act
somewhere else from tom brady to brett
favre to peyton manning i can't help but
wonder whether or not he's thinking
maybe maybe i'll get me one of those
maybe i'll go play somewhere else maybe
if tom brady calls it quits in tampa i
can go reunite with bruce arians i you
know he's a guy who's never gotten the
attention that i think he believes he
deserves it's a great way to get
attention if you start laying the
foundation for playing somewhere else
next year if the steelers cut him but
again that that's not for today but it's
definitely on the table for discussion
in the coming days and weeks i mean no
doubt listen you don't sit there after
the game and sit on the bench for a half
hour i knew right after the football
game they were interviewing baker
mayfield and you could see big ben in
the background sitting on the bench and
you knew
you know juju smith schuster also
sitting there why contract theory not
sure he's going to be back there in
pittsburgh steelers that's the kind of
thing guys do to go
wait that this could be over let me sit
here and take this in one more time and
just you know remember the smell of the
stadium and the sight and just what it
was like to be in this you know great
heinz field and all that that's what
that moment looked like to me and then
crying and then again of course he's
thinking about it because you said it i
hope they want me back but i'm gonna
take time with my family and talk about
that so everything is on the table right
now i have a hard time mike i would say
this i don't think they're gonna make
him pay any money back like if the
indianapolis colts aren't going to make
andrew luck pay money back then damn if
pittsburgh makes him pay money back i'll
be pissed off with them they're going to
have to hear about it but well we'll see
where this goes we'll see where this
goes but it's a legit question about big
ben here and we'll see and i don't know
here's another tom brady like go
somewhere else and maybe i have one more
swung song i think it's like big ben's
on his last leg and maybe he gets one
more year in pittsburgh and he's lucky
if he gets that i think is the way it
looks right now
we talked earlier this year about the
500 club even though it's more of a
regular season deal there are 500 yard
passing performances in the postseason
and ben roethlisberger had one
have we ever seen a worse 500 yard
passing performance in our lifetimes
with four interceptions and and he had
to throw 68 passes because they were
losing so badly i mean 500 yards is 500
yards but come on come on he had four
picks he was not good last night he was
not a good 500 yards no no it was not
you know i mean listen you look at like
500 yard performances and in fact you
look at the majority of them it ends up
with teams you know the losing team when
you throw it for 500 yards it usually
means something bad has gone wrong and
we have to throw every play to come back
and win the football game but yeah they
had to throw the ball 68 times and 500
yards because of some of the missed
throws and mistakes he made early in the
football game and then they just had to
throw at every play because you got to
extend the game then okay we got to make
the clock stop and we gotta play as many
plays as we can possibly play to
hopefully shut the difference down of
the 35 point lead and all those things
but again mike it's all about everything
you know with big you know big ben
certainly not great the predictability
of the throws and the offense you know
the second half it's something we've
talked about a lot through the last
month you know that they came out they
were aggressive they pushed the ball
down the field instead of looking to
like oh we're just going to execute and
go four yards at a time they came out
and actually we're like we're going to
put pressure on you and we're going to
look for 15 and 20 and 30 yard gains and
then when you look for that the five
yard gains are wide open and now they
run for 10 yards just a bad approach by
their offense all together the last six
or seven weeks of the year and you know
i don't want to talk about pittsburgh
too much because cleveland is this the
man of the hour
let me just say one last thing yeah the
501 yards passing from ben
roethlisberger was only the second
ever 500 yard passing game in the post
season the first was tom brady in super
bowl 52 yeah and both quarterbacks lost
sure the game right with 500 passing
yards in the postseason it's amazing all
right the browns are amazing
the browns without odell beckham jr
remember how pissy they got sorry london
when when people started pointing out
they may be better off offensively
without otto beckham jr i don't think
they get this far with odo beckham jr
frankly we'll never know maybe we'll
know next year but i don't think they
get that far this year the offense has
been great kareem hunt had a couple of
touchdowns last night now look it was
opportunistic defense right place right
time make things happen but jarvis land
i remember when they traded for jarvis
landry three years ago chris i remember
thinking
this guy is the quintessential afc north
receiver this is heinz ward this is
tough hard-nosed determined and that's
what we saw last night you know
sometimes you'll watch a game and you'll
see a guy who's got another level of
effort and desire than everyone else
around him and that was jarvis landry
and that attitude given his status on
that team surely spilled over to the
other guys when he's locked in when he's
dialed in when he's focused motivated
and determined that spills over to the
teammates and that's one of the reasons
why they played as well as they did
because he was possessed last night well
yeah he played well i mean their whole
team played well you know again i don't
know you know again i don't know about
the odell beckham jr thing either i'm
not gonna let you just sneak that
comment in there just go buy it okay i
don't know i mean i think they could
have put you and me at receiver last
night and they still would have a chance
to win with the way the game played and
the way pittsburgh looked crappy on the
offensive side of the ball but you're
right mike i mean the attitude of their
football team jarvis landry fits it
perfect they want to run the football
smash your face he wants to go over the
middle of the field catch the ball like
he did in the long touchdown pass make
people miss run through arm tackles he
does fit their attitude of their
football team he's a great leader that
way you know he's not a superstar
receiver but he's a really really damn
good receiver and he improves the
overall culture of your football team i
think that's what you love about jarvis
landry uh but you know that that their
running game
baker you know the fact that the game
never had to really get into cleveland
like feeling like well we have to go
outside the box and make a play they got
to run the ball and they got to go
oh wait we're in the lead so let's make
quick throws and get the ball out of
your damn hand so tj watt and company
don't you know strip sack fumble and get
them back in the football game and i
think they just approached it all the
right way once they got the lead and
baker was pretty damn good
28 nothing first quarter lead first time
that's happened since the 1970 merger
apparently there was a 1969 playoff game
between the oilers and the raiders where
there was a 28 nothing first quarter
lead that's the last time it happened
and baker mayfield wasn't pressured all
night when you consider joe betonio one
of the guys who got bit by the covet 19
bug and they didn't practice until
friday
no practice until friday is that going
to be the next request from jc tread or
the brown center in the nfl practice is
over we don't need practice on wednesday
or thursday of any week we just need a
walk through on friday and look how
baker mayfield sprayed the ball around
look that's one of the ingredients for
mayfield playing well if you keep guys
out of his face he's going to play well
i mean that applies to most quarterbacks
but especially him and i thought tj watt
would be all over baker mayfield it
didn't happen it didn't happen and that
allowed the browns to to really dictate
offensively and it helps when you feel
like it's all going your way speaking to
tj what i couldn't help but think about
his words to me from three or four weeks
ago yeah about what it's like in that
stadium when it's empty and they had
like 2500 people there last night it's
basically empty the energy's not there
you have to make your own energy so it
takes a while to make your own energy
meanwhile you're down 28 nothing by the
time you got the motor wrapped yeah that
was an issue last night too definitely
definitely an issue definitely listen
fans there when you're down and then
okay you make a play those are the kind
of things that can kind of swing the
pendulum of momentum too
you know it's unfortunate it's the
disadvantage of defenses this year i
think it's part of the reason we've seen
the most scoring in the history of
football this year and all these things
because yes defense is an emotional game
crowds fans they add to the emotions and
then that makes the offense like whoa
this place is going crazy and oh my gosh
i think tj watts foaming out of the side
of his mouth this is getting crazy out
here and that's what you know a good
defensive team feeds off of it's hard to
do that in the environment we're seeing
right now but yeah they took that
element out of the pittsburgh steelers
game or attack their defense you know
ability to create chaos i think that's
the advantage maybe cleveland you get by
playing a team three times you get a
good feel for like wait what to do what
not to do whoa i learned if i hold the
ball too long they're gonna hit me and
bad things are gonna happen so let's get
the damn ball out quickly and they got
better and better each time they played
pittsburgh and uh yeah baker was great
understanding the game last night and
what he had to do with the lead and
everything like that just the right
touch of protecting the ball yet okay
i'm not going to be so conservative that
i'm going to leave 15 and 20 yard
completions on the field when they come
back and i thought that was really the
best thing he did to close the game out
very rarely but it does happen there's
this ding dong which is dead moment in
the afc north where the steelers can be
thrown to the side i remember in 2005
there was a bengals win late in the
regular season that made everyone say
hey the the balance of power has shifted
it's the bengals now sea is steelers and
then the steelers turned around ran the
table and then right the super bowl is
the sixth seed coming out of the afc
there's no there's no chance for them to
rectify this year but before we pivot to
the other game
from sunday that we want to talk about
in this block
the idea that you've got ben
roethlisberger's
future in question juju smith schuster's
contract is up james connor's contract
is up there could be some major changes
to that roster
they don't get a quarterback chris they
are going to be and we've talked about
this multiple times throughout the
course of the season with lamar jackson
in baltimore joe burrow in cincinnati
and baker mayfield and cleveland the
steelers are going to be relegated to
periodically what we've seen from browns
and bengals over the last 20 years if
they don't get a quarterback and they
went 20 years from
terry bradshaw to ben rothersberger
they're not going to be able to get away
with a protracted period without a
franchise quarterback they better have a
plan b or there going to be team d in
the afc north well and listen they're
you're right they're they're at the end
of the lifeline for this football team
that we see right here i mean yeah big
ben it's whether you want to bring them
back one year or not you better start
thinking about drafting your next guy or
whoever that is you got to have a plan
certainly you know the offensive line it
that's over they got to redo it it's
over the the the shelf life of that has
moved on they got to find new pieces
there and kind of change the player they
have there running back of course they
need a running back they need to go out
and get a stud
i mean that's an issue with their
football team you know that's why we're
talking about them being gone they can't
even run the ball it's it's not even we
don't even think about it forget to run
the ball let's figure out another way to
throw the ball four inches so that has
to go and then you know hey listen the
defensive line you got guys you know
coming to the end of their contracts
things like that you know but
quarterback running back offensive line
depth on defense mike that's another
issue that pittsburgh's got to think
about it's tj watt and cam hayward
they're in there the whole game and they
were they all their defense wore out at
the end of the year in my opinion we've
said it a few times here over the last
month just a lot of snaps but yeah i
think there's some major major moving
pieces that are going to have to be done
there in pittsburgh this off season
and beyond that look i've lived near and
or in pittsburgh for most of my life i
grew up 60 miles away i'm 100 miles away
exactly right now i lived in pittsburgh
i went to college there i practiced law
there
i know
that fan base even though i'm not a
member of it people think i am i'm not
sorry steelers or maybe you're having no
i think they're saying thank you there
are
there are there are
uh
people in that fan base who will wake up
today seething about mike tomlin
because there's always a group of that
fan base that is ready to get rid of him
yeah because i remember having a report
a few weeks ago there were a few years
ago excuse me weeks years daddy know who
we mean that that there are members of
the limited partnership of the
pittsburgh steelers ownership that have
been pushing art rooney yeah i remember
the owner of the team to make a change
you know i feel like the steelers at
times just
they they they keep their coaches
forever because we're the team that
keeps our coaches forever and we always
want to be the team and said hey we've
had three coaches since 1969. well at
some point maybe you need a fourth coach
there's going to be people who say that
and tomlin unfortunately
gave that crowd some ammunition beyond
there was a curious moment where he
should have clearly gone for two to cut
the lead to eleven if they've gotten it
because then you're down two scores
instead of three yeah or or you're not
down two scores you're down to you know
an eight and a three instead of a 12.
you can get it by with a field goal
right and tie the game up he didn't do
that then he had a punt fourth and one
near midfield it's 35-23 here he is
after the game
on the decision
to
punt the ball the surrender surrender
index was not happy with that 94th
percentile of cowardly punts god who
figures this stuff out during the 2020
season
why did he do it here he is talking
about it after the game
we had had some stops i wanted to pin
him down
and maybe provide the short field for
our offense we had maybe two or three
consecutive stops
and so um i just wanted to keep the
momentum going uh in terms of field
positioning
but we weren't good enough in terms of
doing that
yeah look hey you know there's always a
reason for it but when it doesn't work
then you're the guy who gets who gets
criticized and you know you're at a
point in the game where you have
momentum you're building momentum you
take your shot
you just can't defer indefinitely the
opportunity to come back and try to win
this game the clock is ticking you're
running out of time hey chris if they'd
had another quarter maybe the steelers
would have won the game but you got to
play that way when you have the
opportunity to keep the drive going
you've got to do it you can't just say
we're going to punt here and and play
defense in a game where you've already
given up 35 points you can't just all of
a sudden we're going to say we're going
to play defense well
it's i don't think it's that easy i
don't you know again they're there and
they're in the position they are because
of that defense and their defense you
know for lack of a better phrase whoop
the crap out of cleveland browns in the
third quarter i mean cleveland couldn't
do anything so he's a defensive coach
and he said you know what i am going to
pin him down there one more time instead
of going forward on fourth and one on my
own you know my own side of the ball
we've already missed a fourth and one
earlier in the game we've had a few
other you know short yardage situations
where bad things have happened as far as
interceptions in the tip pass so i i
think he just went okay i'm gonna punt
it out i'm gonna let my defense you know
knock them out one more time and we'll
get the ball back and go down and make
this a one score game i don't
i didn't find that egregious you know i
i understand the thought i i don't think
he's wrong than i thought though i don't
with the way that game was going at that
point i i can get behind his decision
there to punt the ball the other ones
that you talked about some of the
two-point conversions and then deciding
to kick the extra point a few times and
all that i don't know if i believed in
some of those decisions but that one
right there i understand it at least i
do get it when your defense and team is
built through defense i mean then yeah
that's what he he felt at that moment
i'm not gonna be too mad at that one
yeah but but to get back to the point
that i was making
there are members of that fan base that
are going to be looking for any reason
about tom the one we're talking about it
was ben it was this it was marquee's
penalty it was that they're going to
blame tomlin and and look i blame tomlin
for not having his guys ready i blame
tomlin for not having better control
over juju's miss schuster we saw how it
played out with antonio brown remember
the the video in the locker room after
they beat the chiefs in the division
around several years ago and and then
you know
you got to control your guys a little
bit better i understand that he's very
good at getting the most out of his
players and striking a balance where
they can be themselves but he got too
far out of whack with antonio brown for
one set of reasons
and for a different set of reasons it's
gotten out of whack with juju schmidt
schuster to kind of take us back to
where we started it's on the coach to
keep the player from creating these
issues and you know the coach's attitude
after they lost to the bengals when juju
was dancing on the logo before the game
was that's no big deal that stuff
doesn't motivate
they had just told you after the game it
did motivate it i mean how stubborn can
you be chris that you don't take a step
back and ask yourself are these antics
detrimental what are they doing to help
us win what are they doing to cause us
to lose they're not doing a damn thing
to help us win so why are we doing it
why are we putting stuff out there why
is juju saying stuff like the browns is
the browns it's not helping you win you
got to school your guys a little bit
better on how to deal with those moments
when they're talking to the media period
well i think that's answers your
question about them whether they want to
win next week and those things because
that's that's just them
they they're this confident attitude
that it's pittsburgh they're kind of
renegade-ish
yeah we'll spout off at the mouth
okay but we're gonna get on the field
and you're gonna see us in person and
we're big and we're bad and we're gonna
kick your butt that's kind of the way
mike tomlin coaches his football team
but yeah over the last few years we've
seen a little bit of that go maybe to
the overconfident a little cocky phase
to where it has hurt their football team
down the stretch whether it is that year
with a b
you know not playing week 17 and then
just missing the playoffs or the
jacksonville divisional loss like we
talked about yeah there's something
there maybe that's something mike tomlin
goes back to and looks at and goes okay
wait the end of the year we have gotten
a little you know
too big for our britches that way and
maybe there is something i need to do to
kind of bring us back down to earth but
also they let the juju smith and all
that go juju smith schuster stuff go
because he was doing it all year and
they were 11-0 and they were winning and
that's just the way they were but uh it
obviously obviously came back to bite
them in the butt
yeah just the way we are works until it
doesn't and when it doesn't that's when
you need to come up with something else
and look
you need to understand the reality in
which the sport operates one of the
reasons why so many people connected to
sport make so much money is because
people are intensely interested in it
there is a huge army of media that
covers it that's we devote our lives to
covering the nfl there are times when i
ask myself what am i really doing to
help society here i'm covering a sport
and i spend every waking moment doing it
you know but it there's a market for it
and with all the people
who are covering the sport and listening
to everything you say it's incumbent on
the player the coach in the organization
to get it right it's not that hard to
get it right it shouldn't be left to
people
interpreting what someone says
you know based upon the way they say it
instead of what they really meant you
don't get the benefit of that doubt
anymore not the nfl you said it you said
it you put it out there and somebody's
gonna run with it
so it's on them it's on them to fix it
that's one of all the things the
steelers need to fix this off season one
of the things they need to fix is making
sure they're not letting their players
say things that can and will be used
against them on the field that's job
number one it shouldn't be that hard to
do but it definitely needs to be done
yeah i i i agree that has to be you know
reigned in a little bit there in
pittsburgh there's no doubt about that
and yeah yeah i'm with you there too
with the you know oh the media makes a
bigger deal but no no stop that i'm so
sick that's why we're here talk there's
a it's why everybody's here it's why
everybody's here it's why the football
players are there the fans in their
stadium it's all part of this great
cycle that makes great for american
sports and don't say the media made a
bigger deal about it because nobody made
a bigger deal about it oh wait then the
team that was playing the guy so the
media didn't do it you know that was
that was real it was a real comment a
real emotion with a real person and a
real face and then the guy and the team
in the browns uniforms they thought it
was real too and they made it a real
thing in their locker room i can't stand
that talk about media fabrication stop
anything you say can and will be used
against you that's message number one
for all pr executives with every team to
communicate to coaches players
everyone and again it's not that hard
and if it is that hard then you need to
be like bill belichick and say as close
to nothing as possible but that's where
the rubber meets the road on building
your brand right because it's hard to
build a brand if you're not talking you
have to embrace these opportunities to
talk well you got to be careful what you
say and and when you ask juju smith
schuster to talk about the browns how
hard is it to just say man the browns
are really good the browns have had a
rough history and they need to be proud
of what these players have done to turn
this around because it used to be a time
where you look at the browns and you
just say the browns is the browns the
browns isn't the browns anymore how hard
is that how hard is that chris no i know
i hear you mike it's uh they gotta work
on that juju is definitely gonna work on
that no doubt
now he's gonna be working on it for a
different team prediction he's not gonna
be a stealer next year i would agree
they can't keep everybody we talked
about the issues they have they got
chase claypool who's going to be their
star receiver and deontay johnson he's
getting to a point where they're going
to have to pay him too and i think they
like him better as well he's a little
more versatile in his talent i i would
i'm with you i would expect to see juju
in a different team next year
maybe maybe playing for the browns next
year
he fits that style of play
it would be it would be that would be
uh awesome if it works out that way or
the ravens or the ravens he fits that
style of play too although he'd be doing
a lot more blocking than would be
kissing patches
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports